so i want to start today with one of the
two big areas where there is
a particularly high amount of
disinformation spreading right now now
earlier in the week we talked about one
such area and that's coveted in vaccines
the i don't even know what to call it
it's almost like colony calling it the
launch seems weird it's almost like a
product but the breakthrough of the
omicron variant into the news which
started on the day after thanksgiving
last week and led to
two very very shaky days in the stock
market that's one topic that has lent
itself to significant disinformation
right-wing media and republicans going
crazy with false claims about the
variant itself false claims about covid
false claims about vaccines etc etc we
covered that monday we covered it to
some extent yesterday tuesday the other
area that is
being victimized by disinformation from
the right at this point in time
is the economy
and by the economy that includes the
supply chain stuff
employment
inflation
and a few other areas that's another
area of significant disinformation with
such
esteemed talking points from the right
as
inflation is never going to end and it's
going to destroy the economy
nobody wants to work anymore because of
unemployment and there's no workers and
the job situation is a disaster
etc etc you guys have heard a lot of
these uh talking points oh and also
there's no uh chinese-made tchotchkes
for christmas on the shelves thanks to
joe biden okay so those are the kind of
general topics
when we actually look
at the economic data
that is generally accepted as signaling
how the economy is doing now i'll get
back to that because that's not a
trivial matter there are measures we
generally accept to tell us about the
economy we could say these are the wrong
measures but we're going to get back to
that when you look at those measures
things actually look okay
um a few
new as we are now into december a few
new bullet points of data that were
released today
initial
jobless claims meaning new unemployment
claims
fell to their lowest level
last month november since november of
1960
on what's called the seasonally adjusted
basis okay that's the the week before
thanksgiving
um now unadjusted numbers increased and
this is an important thing to understand
there were 199 000 new unemployment
claims during the week ending november
20th the week before thanksgiving
now those have been what's called
seasonally adjusted this is an accepted
method for getting what we might call a
truer
number
which controls for the layoff patterns
that are expected based on the time of
year that it is there are
industries including retail
agriculture and others
which have seasonal patterns for hiring
and laying people off and they don't
really represent
a true hire or layoff in some sense so
there's this process called adjustment
now if you don't adjust the numbers
claims actually did go up a little bit
by 18 000 to almost 259 000 that week
before thanksgiving but the general
picture
is that these are very low numbers for
new unemployment claims so that's one
side of the equation it actually looks
pretty good
um the labor department actually
expected many more people to apply for
unemployment benefits for the first time
in that week before thanksgiving they
anticipated 70 000 more it was actually
only 18 000 more and that's a good thing
by this metric okay
now there's a question as to whether you
know i said the lowest in 52 years
we have changed a number of things over
that 52-year period and so there's a
legitimate question as to are we really
comparing apples to apples when we
compare 2021 to 1969 or some period in
between because there have been changes
in that interim period for example some
states have made it harder to get
unemployment particularly since the
great recession of 2008-2009
so that would reduce the number who even
apply because they know it's harder to
actually get the benefits that's that's
that's fair that could be a factor
on the other hand
since the start of the pandemic more
people are aware that such benefits
could be made available to them so that
would be a factor that compared to the
70s and 80s for example makes more
people apply generally speaking you take
a very top-line look new unemployment
claims are very very low on an
unadjusted basis on an adjusted basis
dating back uh five decades
really pieces of six decades all the way
back to 1969. so that's one thing what
about job creation on the other side of
unemployment is job creation well
private payrolls went up
by 534 000 in november
that's quite a bit better than the dow
jones expectation of 506 000 new jobs
expected was 506 actual was 534.
um leisure and hospitality saw again
um companies with more than 500
employees saw a big gain companies with
over a thousand employees saw an even
bigger proportional gain
and so that's all pretty good by the
standards that we use so the question
marks now are
what happens with omicron and to what
degree does that impact the economy at
least in the us and this is an economic
statement i'm making not a public health
statement there does not seem to be much
if any appetite for anything that would
approximate a shutdown or a lockdown of
any kind
now whether it will make sense from a
public health standpoint first we need
to know how serious omicron is we still
don't
but that's a public health question
dealing with this as an economic
question it doesn't seem like there's
really much appetite for that what
happens with supply chain um and are
these even good metrics and that's
something that is a different question
you know there are systemic problems
with the economy that i talk about all
the time that i know many of you are
aware of which aren't part of this
analysis when we look at new
unemployment claims or job creation or
whatever we aren't talking about wage
growth we're not talking about the
reality that the minimum wage in most of
the united states
is not a living wage as defined by can
you even get a basic two-bedroom
apartment in the place where you are
employed at the minimum wage
those are systemic problems that still
exist and there's no question that the
metrics we use fall woefully short that
being said
the right accepts these metrics and so
on their own terms it's very difficult
to argue that we have a bad economy
right now we haven't solved not
everybody has health care
no that doesn't change but by the
standards the right accepts things are
actually looking okay and it's important
to understand that when you hear their
despairing talking points on fox news
and elsewhere
one of our sponsors is magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and tasty like
the cereals i loved as a kid but without
the sugar or the carbs every serving of
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar only
four net carbs 140 calories and packed
with 13 grams of protein perfect if
you're doing keto perfect if you're
doing low carb great if you're just
trying to reduce your excess sugar
intake and because it's packed with
protein it's great before or after a
workout magic spoon flavors include
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry and cinnamon they're bringing
back cookies and cream they're bringing
back maple waffle you can build your own
variety box and try them all magic spoon
is so confident in the product if you
don't love it as much as i do they will
refund your money no questions asked go
to magicspoon.com pacman the link is
underneath this video and you'll get
five dollars off when you use the promo
code pacman at checkout